thank you Peter and welcome everyone so
as Peter mentioned I'm joined here today
by senji Aaron Walla and Butler
Schneider's on the phone she's the lead
of the group that works on the sequenced
viewers at NCBI and we also have
Ravindra with us in the room today to
help answer questions so the idea today
is in part to advertise the fact that we
now have track hubs available and ncbi's
genome browser the genome data viewer
and gives some demonstration of how to
find track hubs and then how to connect
them and see what they look like in the
displays so today's topics are going to
be what is a track of maybe some of you
are not familiar with track hubs so I'll
give a very brief introduction to what a
track up is and then still in the slides
show you how you can search for track
hubs within the genome data viewer and a
bit on how to connect to those and
display those and then I'll jump into
the viewer itself and do a live demo
just emphasizing some of those features
and I'll wrap up with some general
features of the genome data viewer such
as how to share your browser view once
you've configured that so let's start
with what is a track up and I put this
reference up here for two reasons one
it's a it's a great source of background
information on what track hubs are so if
you're not that familiar with them this
would be a good place to get information
it also reminds me that track hubs are
not an NCBI product so I don't want to
what I want there to be any confusion
about that these were developed by the
good folks at UCSC so from a user's
point of view a track hub is simply a
method of displaying annotation data
these data can be epigenomics proteomics
they can be expression data features
like transcription start sites that sort
of thing these are typically pretty
large files and formats like big bed
bigwig and bam
and the real advantages of track hubs
are that the data are on a remote server
relative to you so that you don't have
to maintain the data and also whenever
you ask the browser to retrieve a
certain bit of data it only has to
retrieve what is being displayed in your
browser
at the moment that range of genomic
coordinates but also whenever you ask
the browser to retrieve a certain bit of
data it only has to retrieve what is
being displayed in your browser at the
moment in other words that range of
genomic coordinates so it doesn't have
to pull everything that's in that
project it only pulls what it needs to
show in that particular view and so that
makes loading the tracks pretty fast so
as you can imagine as more and more
track hubs have become available there
needed to be a way to organize them and
have a good search interface to find
them so the track hub registry came into
being primarily from the folks at the
MDL and EBI and I encourage you to look
at this website track hub registry org
to get more background on that and a
good point of our genome data viewer is
that we provide a search interface so
you can easily search just using free
text this track hub registry so I'm
going to start here on the genome data
viewer homepage and I've blown up the
section here on the right where you can
choose the assembly and that's to point
out that you didn't need to make sure
you're working in the correct assembly
version or the annotation data that you
want to use annotation data is of course
mapped to a particular version so the
the track hub registry has many
different organisms and it often has
more than one assembly for a given
organism so make sure you choose the
correct assembly there so once you do
that you can either click on that
browser genome button or you could use
the search box up above to locate
yourself to a particular chromosome or
region on a chromosome or a gene or
something like that let's just say you
click on that browse genome button
you're going to get a view like this of
the genome data viewer and on the left
hand side of that page are what we call
widgets so there's a search widget and a
blast widget and the one we're going to
be talking about today and using is the
user data and track hubs widget so to
expand that a bit within that widget is
an options menu
you can see expanded on the right there
and under options is a selection for
track hubs this is also by the way or
where you could load up your local files
of user data so if you click on track
hubs that's going to take you into a
track hub configuration menu where you
can start your search and so here you
can input the the URL for the hub if you
happen to know that you can also
restrict by data type if you want
genomics transcriptomics proteomics many
cases just searching all you know any of
those is fine and so let's say I wanted
I knew that I wanted hubs associated
with the gem code project I can simply
type gem code in there it go and on this
particular day that retrieved three
different hubs and keep in mind this is
from the grch37 or hg19 assembly and so
you have gen code related data of
different types long non-coding RNA race
data predicted micro RNA target sites
and project called file OCFS CSF so
let's say I'm interested in that I check
that box that changes of display of the
menu then lists all of the tracks that
are in that particular hub and I'll show
this in more detail when I get into the
live demo but at the bottom of that list
it also shows you other assemblies on
which this track of is available so it's
a little difficult to tell on the slide
but those are grayed out because they
wouldn't be able to display in the hg19
assembly but at least you know that
these are available so there's the other
human assembly HD 38 the current
assembly and then assemblies for Mouse
chicken fruit fly and C elegans then
when you select the tracks that you want
to load up you just check a box for the
tracks that you want you get a nice
green light on the right there when the
tracks load up and then you hit the
configure button and it adds those
tracks into the bottom of your view
those should be displaying as
green-tinted tracks that are not on my
monitor for some
but it loves to tracks at the bottom the
two that I had requested and I have
zoomed in here to a particular gene and
if we wanted to look at that more detail
we could zoom in even farther and so we
see here that the splice donor
predictions are lining up with one end
of an exon and the splice acceptor
predictions with the other so that that
looks good so that's all I had to do for
the slides I'm gonna now jump into the
genome data viewer and do a bit of live
demo so here I am on a browser in the
genome data viewer I just want to back
up a bit and you know give you a little
perspective on why we think using track
hubs is important so we have this let me
increase the zoom level on this page a
bit so you'll see up here at the top we
have this nice array of over 600
eukaryotic refseq genome assemblies in
their annotation and so as more people
put data into track hubs you'll be able
to align this other source of data in
the same viewer with the NCBI
annotations with the overall goal is
that having two or more different
sources of annotation might be able to
come up with some new insights or at
least make some better annotations so
that's sort of the overall goal here
with that little introduction I'll jump
into the genome data viewer and see how
these track hubs can help facilitate
that goal so I'm gonna go ahead and
choose grch37 there are in fact many
more hubs available for grch38 but I'm
just using this as an example I'm going
to click on browse genome and that's
loading the page okay so as always the
viewer comes up with a default set of
tracks let me see if I can zoom in a bit
more so I'm gonna close a couple of
these widgets over here from right now
and open up this user data and track
hubs widget so I've got no track ups or
other tracks right now so if I want to
go to that configuration menu I go to
the options menu and click
track hubs and so now I can search for
any number of things and this is a very
vertical versatile search interface so
let's say I want to pull up that file of
CSF project and maybe I don't remember
the whole name there I can use wildcards
here so Philo Astor it and hit go and it
finds that project for me so that's a
nice feature now I check that box and
again you're gonna see the list of
tracks here that are available for this
particular hub so we have big bed tracks
bigwig tracks in this particular set and
you may notice that some of these tracks
are in red so when a provider puts
together as track hub submits it to the
track hub registry he can mark a certain
set of tracks as a default set of tracks
so all of these up here in black are the
default set these other others are not
marked as a default but you can indeed
load these up if you want so you know
maybe these are sort of some some type
of supporting data for example this
Philo's CSF power is a measure of the
metric statistical power that's what
that red color is about and here are
those other assemblies that I mentioned
okay so let's go ahead and pick the
philo CSF novel set I'll check that box
and you get some configuration options
here but you do notice that get this
green dot those of you paying attention
will see that track validated with
issues will eventually you know of
course fix this but this is an issue
only with chromosome and M the
mitochondrial genome so it's not going
to affect the ability to load up a track
for nuclear genome so that looks good
and I will go ahead and click configure
then before we look at the sequence
viewer I want to point out over here on
the left so it now displays that track
that I loaded and there's this very
handy
description link here so if you want to
learn more about this particular project
you can click on description and this is
provided by the hub provider and so each
of the different types of tracks are
discussed here and so we see that this
novel track for instance shows potential
protein coding regions that are not
currently annotated as protein coding
exons so that's what this particular
track is all about okay so I think what
I'll do is clean up some of the tracks
here we see our Philo CSF novel regions
down here at the bottom and by default
the viewer comes in at least for human
showing all of human chromosome 1 so
this is all of chromosome 1 let me get
rid of some of these other tracks here
just to clean this up a bit
I can get rid of that one too and you
may or may not know this you can also
move tracks around so if I wanted to put
this hub track right up there below the
genes track I can do that let's say I
want to focus in on a particular gene
region so I can go back up to the Search
Widget and let's look for the CSK gene
c-terminal sark kinase gene so it's now
going to focus in on that region ok and
so here we have our track hub I moved it
up so it's in between the NCBI gene
annotation and the ensembl gene
annotation and so these are the features
that come with with this particular
track you can mouse over those you get
some more information if you wanted the
exact sequence of that region you could
get that out of here with this fast data
view and these are colored differently
based on the Strand that they're on so I
think Green is plus grande red is minus
strands so we see some features in this
gene that you know are showing up in
regions that some are and some are not
you know in regions that are currently
annotated as protein coding this is this
is actually a bi prime UTR region up
here
and of course you can zoom around in the
browser if you want you could zoom out
and see what this looks like on nearby
genes okay
so let me check my notes here real quick
to see if horn let's do another search
and we'll add another track so I could
go back either through this track hubs
menu or in fact I could just click on
this configure button here and that will
get me back into this search interface I
could you know close this up if I want
to clean it up but to do another search
all you have to do is click on this
magnifying glass here and let's say we
want to add a track for epigenomics type
that in there you go
and so in grch37 that shows us four
tracks I'm gonna ultimately pick this
top one here the cottony lab but I want
to show you another another feature here
so if I want to search let's say I'm
specifically interested in looking for
DNA signatures so I can just search for
DNA's in this particular case and this
assembly comes up with not exactly the
same sets but it does include this one
and so I'll check this one for the
cottony lab and we'll connect to that
one and so now we see we see all the
track's Avella 4 available for that so
many of these are not part of the
default set but there's a large number
of possibilities to choose from here you
can of course narrow things down here by
closing these carrots and not sure what
other genomes this is available on but
we can go down to the bottom so it's
also available for Mouse let me go back
up to the top if I can get my mouse to
cooperate so let's just put up this
imputes ES 17 combined DNA Streck this
is a bigwig track now not a big bed
track so I checked that I've got the
green light I'll click configure
and there now it's added in this track
so if I want to go back and look just at
that's yes K Jean I can use the region
menu up here and say go to Jean with PAD
that's just a little space on the side
and so now let me move this track up now
so it's right under our annotation there
okay what's right on the ensembl
annotation we have a nice signature here
right at the beginning of this five
prime UTR and these show up pretty
nicely and the surrounding genes as well
so that's the basic idea you can add
multiple tracks that way and you still
have the options of configuring in a
couple different spots so let's do one
more thing here I will let's say we want
to look at this file Oh CSF in
Drosophila for the same gene
so I'll just right click up here on the
title and open a new browser window for
the gdb home page and I gotta make that
a little smaller and so now I want to
search in fruit fly and there's only one
assembly in fruit fly so I don't have to
worry about that so I'll just go ahead
and click on browse genome and let's go
ahead and narrow that to the same gene
region in the search box here and it's
loading up and ok so we've got the CSK
gene there let me go ahead and clean
this up a bit all right so when I open
up the trek widget here and let me zoom
in a bit so I should already have that
file of CSF track available because I
called it up earlier in human so I can
select that and I could get a
description if I wanted to I can just go
ahead and say configure
take me into the menu and so now I'm
looking at the disciple of melanogaster
six genome annotation so I will check
that box
got the green light so click on
configure and there we have very similar
sort of annotations there it's in a
little different spot it's amazing the
CSK gene is this well conserved between
human and flight I wanted to I could
move that up again ok so that's it for
that demonstration I'd really just want
to show you a couple more things general
features in the browser and so let's say
you get this configure exactly the way
you want and you want to show this to
one of your colleagues there's a link up
here and let me zoom in on this link up
here at the top of the browser called
share this page so you click on that and
it will generate a URL so you send that
URL to one of your colleagues and they
will see the exact same view that you're
seeing here other thing you can do a
course is use the Tools menu scroll over
here a bit so here you can print this as
a publication quality PDF you can send
that to somebody and I don't want you
get confused on this share this page
link you may know that within the
sequence viewer there is a link to view
you could use that and it will still
display these same tracks but it will
just be the sequence viewer it won't be
the whole genome data viewer you so you
won't have the widgets over there so I'm
finished with my bit and we'll open it
up see if there are any questions any
general questions Peter thanks Wayne no
there are no questions right now please
be sure to if you think of anything
afterwards please be sure to write to us
and I think is a slide that shows you
some contact information here in a
minute
so if you have any questions about the
genome data viewer or any questions
about the webinar program in general you
can write to us also some useful links
for good resources for learning about
NCBI in particular the NCBI insights and
you can sign up for announcements and
you can check out our YouTube channel
where this video will live so thanks for
coming and we'll talk to you next time